morning everybody I'm back it's seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
start of a big week for Boris Johnson as
he prepares to face the MPS who could
decide his political future later on
today we're expecting a dossier of his
party gate defense to be published as he
tries to convince MPS he didn't
knowingly or recklessly mislead
Parliament plus China's president heads
to Moscow after an arrest warrant is
issued for President Putin over alleged
war crimes in Ukraine we'll be joined by
a former international criminal court
prosecutor and later we'll be joined by
Donald Trump's former National advisor
that's John Bolton it's Monday the 20th
of March make or break Boris Johnson's
partygate defense to be published later
his team insists he'll be Vindicated
Chinese president heads to Moscow just
days after the international criminal
court issued an arrest warrant for
Vladimir Putin
war crimes are top of the agenda as the
UK hosts the summit to help track down
those guilty of War crime atrocities
investors watch anxiously to see if the
rescue of Credit Suisse will steady
stock markets around the world
the campaign to ban trophy hunting the
argument rages over how successful the
UK's new law will be in protecting
wildlife
good morning everybody Boris Johnson's
political future could hang in the
balance this week as he tries to
convince MPS that he didn't mislead
Parliament over party gate his defense
against those claims is expected to be
published later on today before he gives
evidence to the Privileges committee on
Wednesday that's going to be box office
isn't it you can watch it of course here
on Sky his team insists the evidence
will show he didn't knowingly mislead
MPS
we know from official reports that there
were at least 15 parties in dining
Street between May 2020 and April 2021.
in December of 2021 Boris Johnson was
repeatedly challenged on those parties
and repeatedly told the House of Commons
he knew nothing about them an interim
committee report published earlier this
month said it should have been obvious
to him that rules were being broken his
defense will be published today and is
likely to include the advice he was
given at the time the Privileges
committee will cross-examine the former
pm on Wednesday and decide whether he
deliberately misled the house and if so
whether he should be suspended any
sanction will have to be approved by MPS
in a vote it could come down to whether
or not they believe him when he told the
commons no rules were broken
all guidance was followed completely
during number 10. I have been repeatedly
assured since these allegations emerged
that there was no party and that and
that no covid rules were broken I'm
second myself and Furious about that
but I repeat what I have said to him
that that I've been repeatedly assured
that the rules
the guidance was followed and the rules
were followed at all times
well let's find out more should be
joining us now as our political
correspondent Tamara Cohen good morning
so when we saw those pictures of him
having parties he didn't think there
were parties that's right so partygate
is back and today we'll see Boris
Johnson's written defense of those
parties those pictures ahead of his
appearance in front of the committee
which should be quite fiery on Wednesday
so this is not about whether the party's
happened we know they did or who brought
the suitcases of wine this is whether he
misled Parliament whether what he said
at the time was what he really believed
to be the case whether he was recklessly
misleading MPS now his defenses is
expected when we see it later today we
published by the committee to do two
things we're expecting to see messages
from some of his civil servants and
advisors in Downing Street with some of
the advice they gave him about those
parties which Boris Johnson's team say
will bolster the idea that he was just
doing what he was advised to do I think
we're also going to see him throwing out
a few grenades at the committee and the
whole process which you will have seen
his allies have called a kangaroo court
and a Witch Hunt they say that this
committee which of course has a majority
of conservatives on it is out to get him
so he's going to be mounting this robust
defense and the reason is because the
stakes are really high if he's found to
have lied to Parliament and that
committee can recommend he be suspended
from Parliament and that CAD could lead
to a by-election in his constituency in
him being kicked out by the voters there
so this is a really important moment and
that's why I think Boris Johnson's team
will be fighting it very hard and they
say they believe that he will be
Vindicated okay tomorrow fine thanks
very much indeed now's the chance for
you to have your say on that big topic
of the day what should happen to Boris
Johnson if he's found to have recklessly
misled Parliament why don't you let us
know your thoughts you can tweet me
directly if you would like to what
should happen to Boris Johnson if he's
found to have recklessly misled
Parliament tell us your thoughts and we
will share it with the world on our
breakfast show let us know we've had
lots of replies already we will turn to
some of those a little bit later on in
the program meantime let's tell you
about China's president XI arriving in
Moscow today hoping to help settle what
he calls the crisis in Ukraine in an
article published ahead of his meeting
with Vladimir Putin who said of him a
friend in need is a friend indeed
the importance of the visit this week
really can't be overemphasized a
three-day State visit where president XI
will travel to Moscow today he'll have
informal meetings and an informal dinner
with President Putin tonight before more
serious talks uh tomorrow now look the
two leaders have met many times but the
stakes have a lot higher and the reason
of course is the context of the war in
Ukraine and crucially what China's
position on that war is now China has
always said it is a neutral party in the
conflict that it wants to act as a
peacemaker it says it's one of the few
countries in the world that has the
authority to do that because it hasn't
sold arms to either side it says it
hasn't taken sites but of course the
West would slightly raise an eyebrow to
that because it says that China has been
quietly supplying Russia with Finance
with technology and all-important
diplomatic cover as well so certainly
from president xi's perspective he will
want to be seen to be gaining some
ground as part of this meeting and what
exactly that looks like is very certain
at the moment but be in no doubt the
relationship between China and Russia is
very very important to the Chinese as
well it is countries that do a lot of
trade with each other they share a long
border that's very important to both
sides to keep peaceful and certainly
from the Chinese perspective as well
Russia offers a like-minded Ally in an
increasingly difficult power struggle
with the west and that is very very
important as well so what breakthroughs
if any come out of this remain to be
seen but it is a very very significant
gesture the presidency is choosing to go
on the very week that President Putin
has not only been issued with an
international an arrest warrant from the
international criminal court but is also
pictured walking around occupied
mariopol a very big gesture and a very
important meeting indeed
and more from Helena in the next hour uh
justice ministers from around the world
will meet in London today to pledge help
for the international criminal court in
its investigations into war crimes on
Friday the court issued an arrest
warrant against Russia's President Putin
accusing him of personal responsibility
for the removal of children from Ukraine
to Russia either has more for us this
morning good morning
yes so this meeting has actually been in
the diary for a few months now primarily
it was set up as a way to Garner more
practical support for the court
supporting the form of money personnel
and expertise and to that end the UK has
already pledged it'll give more than a
million pounds to the court this year
and other countries are expected to
follow suit dig a bit deeper into their
pockets but secondly in the wake of that
arrest warrant being issued on Friday
for Vladimir Putin and this is a going
to provide a very visual show of support
for the court and for that arrest
warrant it's a demonstration that the
International Community supporting
Ukraine is also supporting the ICC a
very direct direct Counterpoint to she's
visits Moscow that we've just been
hearing about and saying to everyone
look okay Russia might have China but
look who we've got more than 40 Nations
will be represented at this meeting
they'll be hosted by Dominic Robb the UK
is Justice secretary and also his um
Dutch counterpart at Lancaster housed in
central London will get a press
conference at 5 30 where we're here
what's being decided I'm not sure it
makes it any more likely that the
Russia's president will be going on
trial anytime soon but what this does do
is isolate him even more and also Shore
up support for Ukraine okay for now
either thank you well joining us now is
uh Sir Jeffrey nice who led the
prosecution against the former
Yugoslavian president sloviron milosevic
hello to you sir Jeffrey thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
it's always great to see you
um what does this arrest warrant
actually mean
labels labels Putin as a wanted criminal
the labor will stick with him for his
life unless either he's tried and
acquitted or almost inconceivable the
international criminal court withdraws
the arrest warrant and as a man labeled
as a criminal in that way he can't
travel to any of the countries that are
signed up to the ICC or probably to many
other countries like America either and
he's going to have to live with that
until it's resolved uh but um you point
out that countries that are signed up to
the ICC
um not all of them are not least China
meeting with Xi Jinping later on today
so in reality what impact might it have
on his day-to-day life
well just what I said he can't travel to
the other countries it may also of
course mean that any powers in Moscow
that want to see him couple and we
sometimes hear that there are some
will film emboldened his own people may
not want to be led by a man who is uh
labeled as a war criminal but for the
time being those are the only immediate
and obvious concerns but it's a very
very important and very welcome move
that the ICC has made how important is
it that other countries get involved
with the arrest warrant
well it is of course very important that
the ICC which has been I'm afraid of
much criticized called has eventually
brought out this well warrant we were
rather concerned that maybe it was
delaying action in order to not to
impede peace moves but anyways it's
brought the warrant out so better late
than never
and it's very important that support is
given for the ICC two points I'd like to
make one
um it might be thought helpful for the
International Community to join
Ukrainian parliamentarians
who seek to relieve Russia of its powers
of veto in the security Council by
suspending it in the way that for
example South Africa was suspended for
20 years
um from operating in the U.N and if that
were to happen it would be possible to
get the crime of aggression or more
possible get a crime of aggression
within the jurisdiction of the ICC and
that would be extremely welcome because
everybody we've got many people regard
that as the most appropriate crime to be
tried
second thing is the presence of
Internationals is good but not
necessarily always and absolutely good
and it's a very good thing
that Mr Robb is sharing the speaking
because he has direct knowledge uh uh
going back 19 years now of how once
Internationals got involved in
international Justice they can apply
quite improper pressure on those who are
trying to operate a Judicial machine
because
this is an example but 19 years ago when
I was seeking to get the very best
possible evidence as I imagined it to be
against milosevic for his role in
Australia
these were intercepts of phone calls
that we knew had been made between him
and Ladish for reasons that are still
not entirely clear parts of the
international Humanity stepped in and
simply stopped the investigation when
they stopped it because they had
interests of their own to serve
reputational interests or or security
interests we have no idea we had no idea
at the time when we have little more
idea now
and it would be quite unreasonable to
think that Simply Having Internationals
involved in the court or even in
supporting the court is going to make
that Court a cleaner Court than it
otherwise would be so yes it's great
that they are supporting the court with
money and making it possible for Mr
Carter to do more work and do his work
even better than he may have done it
already
but don't fall into the Trap of thinking
that internationalizing criminal process
is always is going to make it better or
cleaner because because it worked and
the experience I had 19 years ago
um of which Mr Robb will be aware is a
real warning sign
and the truth that I was seeking to
establish then and I've never been able
to establish then all since
led to certain inferences being grown in
a sort of casual way by the team at the
time and those inferences have been
strengthened since by other material
that has come to light making it even
more important
that I was never interfered with in the
investigations that I sought to make so
that's a good point by the way it also
that the caution with which one must
look at both the international criminal
court which has itself been accused in
respect of other matters of being
perhaps partial or subject to
International influence and the point
I've just made
can reinforce a general observation that
the most appropriate setting for Trials
of war crimes in this war
is Ukraine itself and for war crimes
accountability processes to be conducted
by ukrainians and in the Ukrainian and
Russian languages
people sometimes think that's a
surprising proposition to make but you
it's not it's completely obvious if
crimes are committed on your territory
it's your Sovereign right and Duty you
might argue to deal with them
and if America or and Canada have found
themselves in conflict over
a seizure by Canada part of Alaska or if
england was separated from Scotland and
there was a war and war crimes were
alleged that sort of hypothetical
example if you think any of those
countries would allocate responsibility
for dealing with war crimes to France or
Morocco or New Zealand or somewhere of
course they wouldn't they tried them
themselves and so the basic premise is
Ukraine first second Let's Help the
international criminal court but third
don't assume that letting Internationals
get involved will make it a cleaner
court or a better court because it will
still possibly be vulnerable to
International pressure
as always thank you for taking the time
thank you
still to come on the program for you
this Monday morning as the UK hosts a
meeting to discuss potential war crimes
in Ukraine just talking about
outspeaking to former UK NATO
representative Lord Ricketts uh very
shortly
uh shortly after that be speaking to
Dominic grieve former Attorney General
and also former conservative MP as Boris
Johnson sets out his partygate defense
dossier
also be joined by the shadow Minister
for Health and Social care that's Liz
Kendall just after eight o'clock
for all of that though let me tell you
about the Swiss bank UBS it's rescued
the beleaguered Credit Suisse in a
multi-billion pound deal failing to act
according to the Swiss president would
have had Unthinkable consequences for
Global Financial markets let's get more
should we Ian standing by for us in the
city so they bail them out in good
morning
well okay yes this is an absolutely
Monumental deal it's it's like sort of
the the banking equivalent in
Switzerland of Liverpool and Manchester
United merging these are the two big
giants of the earth Swiss bank Etc it
means effectively Switzerland now has
one big global bank now that there are
going to be consequences of this uh for
quite some time not least the fact that
Credit Suisse employs more than 5 000
people here in London most of them work
in the investment banking side of the
business and Colin Kelleher the chairman
of UBS said last night that uh that part
of the business would certainly be
de-emphasized because uh UBS regards
itself as a considerably less Risky
Business than Credit Suisse so I think
there will undoubtedly be job losses
here in London that's the first point
secondly it's what all about the market
reaction now now overnight in the Asia
Pacific region you've seen banking
shares selling off two of which are
quoted here in London Standard Chartered
and HSBC both of those have listings in
Hong Kong which have fallen by around
six and seven percent all of the Asian
stock markets have also Fallen
incidentally but I think it's what
happens in the United States later on
today that will also be pretty critical
because this has again Shone the light I
think it will on some of these mid-tier
and Regional American Banks the likes of
First Republic which we talked about in
the past essentially the Swiss
government had to step in to rescue
credit so oversee this rescue because
there was a loss of confidence credit
Swiss was losing deposits uh people were
taking the money out of the bank and
this of course remember is one of the
world's 50 biggest banks it's a
systemically important bank so I think
there'll be concerns in the United
States about the status of some of these
mid-tier U.S banks in the meantime there
are all sorts of ramifications for
bondholders because a class of
bondholders in credit Swiss have been
completely wiped out whereas
shareholders will be getting something
for their money this is a very very
unusual State of Affairs so I suspect
you will see some forms uh some classes
of banking bonds falling very sharply
when the Market's open this morning as
well I should say by the way in the
pre-market trade shares of UBS are down
some seven percent shares of credit
Swiss are down 61 right now wow and uh
it's good to get your expertise on that
thank you in King live of course 10
o'clock this morning here on Sky News
meantime in other news 70 000 University
staff are striking again today as part
of a three-day walkout over pay and
pensions University and college union
members from 150 different universities
rejected the latest offer for a pay
increase uh it's not just University
stuff let's take a look at other strikes
expected in the coming weeks um driving
test examiners have multiple strike days
planned this week and next there you go
further rail strikes a plan for the end
of the month security guards at Heathrow
will strike for 10 days over Easter
great starting at the end of this month
and into next month and passport office
staff will strike for five weeks from
the third of April talk about that later
on the week actually the impact it might
have on you if you are planning or your
passports run out and you need a new
passport five weeks of strikes at the
passport office yeah really looking at
some of today's other headlines for you
know
uh hundreds of people arrested across
France over the weekend as protests
intensified against President Emmanuel
macron's move to bypass Parliament and
raise the country's retirement age the
French President used a special
constitutional power to push through a
plan to raise the retirement age by two
years to 64 without a parliamentary vote
as a result he now faces and no
confidence vote later on today
a murder investigation has been launched
after a 17 year old boy was stabbed to
death at a house party in Leeds West
Yorkshire police were called to the
party in the early hours of Sunday
morning where the teenager was found and
taken to hospital he was pronounced dead
at the hospital
the government's foods are has quit in
order to freely criticize what he called
insane inaction against obesity Henry
dimbleby the co-founder of the food
chain Leon said ministers were to blame
for two-thirds of UK adults being
overweight or obese because they refused
to impose restrictions on the junk food
industry
and your report suggests that there's a
global shortage of nurses the
international Council of nurses says the
situation should be treated as a global
Health Emergency the report also says
that 40 to 80 percent of nurses
experience mental health and
psychological distress
20 years on since the beginning of the
2003 Iraq war the defense secretary is
due to visit the National Memorial
Arboretum in Staffordshire to lay a
wreath at the Basra memorial wall it's
in memory of the 179 Personnel who lost
their lives in Iraq
a major report on climate change is
being released later on today it's
expected to call for emission targets to
be brought forward or the world will
face a climate catastrophe it'll be the
sixth assessment report of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change and it could be its most Bleak
yet it's fair that in parts of the world
it'll be too hot to live and work in the
decades ahead
we will have more on that later in the
program joined by Mary Robinson chair of
the elders and the former un special
Envoy for climate change
Russia is being accused of stoking
protests spreading propaganda and
backing an alleged coup in Moldova
Vladimir Putin has been accused of
deliberately destabilizing the country
as he seeks to create a land bridge
between Southern Ukraine and the former
Soviet Republic our Europe correspondent
Siobhan Robbins is in the moldovan
capital of kishna and sent this report
on The Invisible War being waged on
Ukraine's neighbors
down with the dictator they shout for
months Rising food and energy costs has
brought protesters onto moldova's
streets but the governments accused
Russia of deliberately stoking the anger
by pushing up prices spreading
propaganda and backing a plot to
overthrow them
something Moscow and moldova's
pro-russian politicians dispute we're
supporting the protest because the life
in our country became too difficult we
as the Parliamentary reflection and
parliamentary party we don't feel this
interference
moldova's pro-western President says
they're fighting a hybrid War under
attack from Kremlin interference as it
tries to destabilize Ukraine's Neighbors
here's an example of growing Russian
interference this is an old video of a
military parade in Romania but it
quickly became an alarmist social media
post shared by pro-russians in Moldova
with warnings the tanks were heading for
their border
monitoring group Watchdog MD claims
Russian disinformation has rocketed
tenfold in the last year we are feeling
the the pressure even from here from
kishuno so basically what I would say is
the the future of the country not to be
too pathetic about it uh
lies at stake but public opinion is
divided in the pro-russian autonomous
region of gagosia many feel closer to
Moscow than the West
at the market no one I speak to believes
Russia is a threat like Valentina they
fondly remember their Soviet past
the government says that Russia is
trying to stir up trouble and interfere
in politics here do you believe that
yep
do you trust President Putin we believe
in everyone she says if a person is
attacked he has to defend his people
but it's not Russian troops Moldova has
to fight the enemy here is invisible the
battlefield largely online Siobhan
Robbins Sky News Moldova
let's have a look at what the papers are
saying this morning should we the Metro
leading on Boris Johnson's claim he has
a 50-page dossier that will clear him of
any wrongdoing over partygate that story
is also on the front of the eye it says
prime minister Rishi sunak has postponed
the announcement of several key policies
because of the publication of the
documents the time says an independent
report due to be released tomorrow will
reveal that the Met police force face is
being broken up if it does not rapidly
overhaul its toxic culture the Ft has
the news that UBS has agreed to buy
credit Suites for 3.25 billion dollars
which is two and a half billion pounds
in English money as Regulators attempt
to prevent the collapse of the Swiss
banking system and finally The Daily
Telegraph also leads on that story it
warns that thousands of jobs in the city
of London could go because of the merger
it's a lot warmer this morning where we
are here in London what about where you
are
warm memories wherever you go
you go the weather sponsored by Qatar
Airways
this week looks mild and unsettled but
temperatures will return to near average
later on perhaps cold in the north by
the weekend
now remember that picture we showed you
before the break it's a huge World War
II mine which has been detonated off the
coast of Croatia local authorities first
discovered the 1500 pound explosive back
in June however in a hugely risky
operation it had to be moved further
away from the city of rieka before
emergency teams performed the controlled
detonation
our top stories for you this morning
make or break Boris Johnson's party gate
defense is to be published later on
today his team insists he'll be
Vindicated
Chinese president heads to Moscow to
meet Vladimir Putin just days after the
international criminal court issued an
arrest warrant for the Russian president
the UK will host a war crimes meeting
later on today following accusations
that the Russian president is involved
in the Abduction of Ukrainian children
well it's a story that we want to talk
about in more detail Lord Peter Ricketts
was the UK's permanent representative to
Nato and a former permanent under
secretary at the foreign office he's
with us this morning good morning thanks
for joining us so there's a warrant for
his arrest what difference will that
make nothing at all decision ping who
doesn't recognize international criminal
court and is very happy with the way
things are I think with Russia suits
China very well so he will continue with
his visit as if that didn't exist what
about for President Putin what
difference does it make to him well in
in his normal life nothing at all I
don't think because he's not about to
leave Russia certainly not to go to any
country that might possibly take action
on this arrest warrant but it still
sends a very strong signal that the head
of a major country is now under an
arrest warrant for war crimes and around
the world you know that sends a pretty
strong signal that we do not accept
there's any impunity for the kind of
behavior that we've seen from Russian
forces under Putin's control
I don't think we'll see him in the Hague
in the international criminal court
honestly anytime soon
potentially provoke him and therefore
prolong the War I don't think so I mean
he's already in real trouble in the war
I think the visit by Xi Jinping is very
helpful to him it bolstes him it shows
him he's got an important Ally in the
world
um but I think he's got to now prosecute
this war war crime warrant or not I
think it's more important to Signal it
sends outside Russia to other countries
who might be thinking of sporting Putin
to Mario Paul
Crimea as well of course and Crimea as
well symbolic I mean mainly a signal
back into Russia that he is capable of
traveling and that he's taking some
credit for having taken the city of
mariopol in many ways it was pretty
laughable really I mean he had to go in
the dead of night nobody around driving
around deserted streets you couldn't see
the extent of the damage and and
desolation in nariable so I mean it was
a pretty empty propaganda exercise I
think which won't have convinced very
many people outside Russia but it was
for a domestic audience I guess I think
it was for a domestic audience and it
was to show the Russians that you know
he has got something out of this awful
devastating War he can at least go when
nobody is around to this smashed up city
of Murray airport you started off by
talking about the Chinese um president
as we look at these images now
um
How concerned does the West need to be
about China cozying up to Russia
I think it's a fact that Russia and
China both see themselves as in a
confrontation with the west and for the
Chinese it's very convenient this War I
don't think they're about to do anything
particular to bring it to an end it
makes Russia weak and dependent on China
gives them access to massive amounts of
Russian oil and gas and it distracts
America from confrontation with China
because it involves them in sporting
Ukraine and Europe so I think the status
grows through it serves Xi Jinping just
fine and what's your view I mean because
depends who sits there um two schools of
thought when it comes to China getting
involved in the war in Ukraine with
Russia and what the West might thus do
about it either China won't because they
need to sell our their goods to people
like us and the Americans and the
Europeans or actually China doesn't care
because they have a ready Market in East
Africa that is developing all the time I
think I mean this China's will decide
what to do in the base of Chinese
interests yeah and I think Chinese
interests are to keep Russia weak a kind
of vassal State and cheap energy
available but also not to burn their
Bridges with Europe or even America as
you say they have enormous trading
interests and they have an awful lot of
dollar deposits in Washington so I don't
think they want to get completely on one
side of the line or the other therefore
I don't think they're going to go all in
to support Putin personally I don't see
them supplying major weapon systems you
know partly because I don't think they
would want them to fall into Ukrainian
hands on the battlefield and then get to
America so they might provide some
Munitions or something but I think it'll
be fairly low level more important
economic support technological support
yes so the relationship with Russia is
strong that means that their peace
proposals are simply diplomatic
wallpaper frankly they're not in any
position to broker a peace deal but I
don't think that they're going to burn
their votes completely with Europe and
the West they've got president macron or
France going on a state visit in a few
days time they will want to keep playing
everyone to Chinese interests
20 years since the Iraq War can you
believe it
um how do you think we should look back
at that
well I believe it was in a way the
pivotal event in international Affairs
since the end of the Cold War why
because after a decade in which we'd
used our Armed Forces on the Blair for
humanitarian good in places like Kosovo
and Bosnia and even in Northern Iraq in
1991 suddenly U.S and UK went into a war
without U.N Authority I think that both
knocked confidence in the west that ever
intervening again in other people's
Affairs it empowered the authoritarians
and I'm afraid it left us in the
non-aligned countries looking
hypocritical because now when we come to
say will you back us against Russia on
Ukraine they say but you invaded Iraq 20
years ago so I think we can still see
the impacts of that devastating decision
today
um it's interesting to I I wonder what
our viewers
um think this morning how they remember
the um Iraq War I know that some of our
leaders are heading up to the Arboretum
later on today
um to pay their respects to those lives
that were lost
depends who you talk to quite a lot of
people that I speak to think that it was
a pointless War
I mean at the time and I was in the
foreign
was absolutely convinced that after 9 11
the risk that weapons of mass
destruction chemical weapons or nuclear
material could get into the hands of
terrorists might prove an even worse
attack than 9 11. and he and George Bush
were convinced that that might somehow
be a way in which the weapons of mass
destruction they thought were in Iraq
could get into the hands of terrorists
that's why I think Blair went to war you
know he honestly believed it at the time
but we weren't prepared for the
follow-up we did a bad job of the
occupation that we found ourselves in
and the region is more violent more
destabilized more people have lost their
lives as a result of the war so what we
would like to believe though weren't we
that Britain or British soil could be
impacted within 40 minutes yes and that
was part of the intelligence that turned
out to be dud intelligence and so that
is part of the reason people are quite
rightly angry I think people genuinely
believed it at the time there was an
awful lot of intelligence around it
turned out to be wrong and therefore the
whole basis of the war was wrong the
fact we didn't get U.N Authority put us
in the on the wrong side of the line
internationally and in a way we've been
paying the price ever since we certainly
have quick thoughts
um perhaps some Boris Johnson
well I mean that's a big sign with all
these things going on in the world that
we've just talked about you know it's a
very dangerous violent world out there
we've got a war crimes conference in
London today
to me this Boris Johnson stuff is really
a distraction dude he's no longer prime
minister yeah of course the parliament's
got to decide you know what his what his
future is going to be but he is not the
top story as far as I'm concerned this
International situation is far more
important for the country good to see
you as always thank you very much you do
for joining us on the program thank you
let us know your thoughts on that or
indeed any of the stories that we are
covering here on the program this
morning like this one perhaps the family
of one of India's most popular Punjabi
hip-hop artists who was murdered last
may have demanded justice as thousands
of people pay their respects at a
memorial service sidhu moose Wala was
shot dead the day after his security
team was publicly withdrawn by India's
new government from Mansa and Punjab uh
Punjab forgive me our correspondent
Neville Lazarus reports
his popularity remains unrivaled with an
ever increasing fan base even after
death
thousands have come to pay tribute to
sidhu musawala
his songs and videos transcend borders
and I watched hundreds of millions of
times
sidhu's killing has been controversial
Rich famous he dabbled in politics and
fought elections A Marked Man he was
provided State security but the new
government publicly announced it would
be withdrawn the family says it left him
exposed a day later his Killers followed
him and gunned him down the authorities
say the killing of sidhu musawala was a
result of gang rivalry and revenge 27
persons including the six gunmen are in
jail the case is ongoing but the family
is unsatisfied with its base and
investigations
his father is campaigning for justice
for his son and has the support of the
people got the person who fired that gun
but who are the people behind it his
father is literally saying okay you
investigate those people
Sandy Joya his childhood friend has come
from Kent she do often stayed with him
when in Britain in fact if you can see
all around the world as well in the UK
Parliament as you know that they raise
this issue because he had the resident
permit for UK the Indian government he
was paying tax here so this government
they're not doing anything Punjabi
hip-hop has become popular with Millions
around the globe
to do its Ambassador
many of sidhu songs have been about
weapons revenge and gangs with songs of
guns and violence begin to imitate the
lives they lead
Neville Lazarus Sky News in Mansa Punjab
no you've probably heard of off street
parking haven't you not like this you
haven't diners at baths Francis Hotel in
Queen Square were treated with this site
on Mother's Day when a car became wedged
against the hotel
basement windows and Fire and Rescue
service said crew freed one of the
occupants from the vehicle while another
was able to get out by himself how did
they get in that position the car
remains stuck but the hotel is open as
normal
they'll be able to teacup that out won't
they probably no whose birthday is it
today you've got a short break to have a
think here's a clue she's starting
Broadcast News and the piano she's great
after a station
hello again everybody before the break
we gave you a clue about whose birthday
it is today she starred in films
Broadcast News Sensational movie if you
haven't seen it you should and the piano
great in that as well did you guess it
it's Holly Hunter she plays Jane Craig
in Broadcast News and Ada McGrath in the
piano along with many other movies as
well she's 65 today she looks amazing
doesn't she happy birthday Holly
now a little earlier we asked you what
should happen to Boris Johnson if he's
found to have recklessly misled
Parliament and we suggested that you
could probably let us know via our
Twitter fees so many of you have already
um KS saying he should be suspended for
30 days face recall petition and then a
by-election if the tour is let him get
away with this it'll show they hold
Parliament and the public in contempt
and Mary Scott also tweeted us this
morning good morning Mary thank you
Johnston should be suspended and barred
from holding a seat as an MP ever again
his laws there should be revoked and he
should pay back all costs for his legal
case I just checked that it's presently
000 pounds of uh your taxpayer money
being used and also Catherine Harrison
Catherine good morning thanks for
letting us know your thoughts
um if he received a fixed penalty notice
for something that he's said quite
adamantly in Parliament never happened
Johnson should be suspended says Rich
Turner unseated and barred from standing
again if there is a legal mechanism for
doing so let us know your thoughts on
that you can tweet me directly if you
would like to at Cape early and excuse
me we have a topic for you every single
day today it is what should happen to
Boris Johnson if he is trying to
recklessly have misled Parliament I
wonder what dominic grieve thinks about
that former Attorney General hello to
you Mr B thanks for joining us on the
program this morning what should happen
to Mr Johnson
well Mr Johnson's explanations have got
to be considered uh by the committee uh
and they've got to do that in an
impartial way and I'm quite sure they're
capable of doing it they're a
cross-party committee uh and they've got
to consider whether in fact the uh
statements he made to the House of
Commons uh were untrue Mr Johnson
certainly does appear to have a
considerable problem he attended some of
the Gatherings which were parties and
yet he said that there weren't any
Gatherings and it's a bit difficult
therefore to understand how he didn't
know that there had been parties going
on at number 10 Downing Street he says
their work events well the photograph
You're just showing rather shows for
itself uh the nature of the Gatherings
which were taking place they don't look
like work events so Mr Johnson's got a
lot of explaining to do and of course
that is against the background of
somebody who has a Serial uh reputation
for telling untruths whenever it suits
him
well he says that he has a 50-page
written document that he's going to
submit today
um his lawyers have been working with
him and he will be able to prove that he
did not mislead Parliament is there a
difference between misleading Parliament
and an intention to mislead Parliament
it's possible for a minister or indeed a
member of the House of Commons to
inadvertently mislead Parliament and if
you do that you should correct the
inadvertent uh mistake you made at the
earliest opportunity it has been quite
notable with Mr Johnson that he and his
ministers have often this led Parliament
on other matters and never corrected the
record but this is a particularly
serious matter because it went right to
the heart of his government but yes it
is possible that the committee could
conclude that although he misled the
House of Commons he didn't do it on
purpose and that he was himself of the
view that um there weren't parties
taking place at number 10 Downing Street
that as I say the photographs make will
seem to me to demand some explanation as
to how he could make those assertions
when he was both attending events of the
kind that you've uh you can see in the
photographs and on top of that there are
some internal emails in which uh he
States this is the most most unsocially
distanced Gathering that has taken place
so it on the face of it he seems to have
known that there were Gatherings which
were taking place which appear to have
been in breach of the lockdown rules
um you are no fan of Boris Johnson it
has to be said you've said he wasn't he
wasn't suitable to be uh prime minister
and that he was taking the country down
a dangerous path um a lot of your
colleagues don't necessarily agree he is
still incredibly popular with the
conservative party and the growing view
is that it would take um somebody of his
character to try to lead the
conservatives uh going forward if you
lose the next election
well I'm afraid that just shows the
elements of the conservative party are
still delusional about Mr Johnson and if
they want to continue along that that
path it's a matter for them but Mr
Johnson is not going to help the
conservative party's electoral fortunes
as for uh his future I have no idea the
the committee has got to act impartially
and as Parliament is not subject to any
higher authority because we have this
thing called parliamentary sovereignty
and there's a privilege of parliament so
no court can investigate what goes on
there it is self-regulating so Mr
Johnson I'm afraid can't complain about
the facts that it is going to be a group
of MPS who are going to consider the
material on Wednesday and listen to what
he has to say and they will have to do
their best to set aside all personal
prejudices and just look rationally at
what Mr Johnson says when he says that
he didn't mislead Parliament and look at
the evidence and they've got to come to
a fair conclusion now I'm quite sure
that they're capable of doing that
you mentioned the Privileges committee
the chairman recused himself step back
because he had previously criticized the
then prime minister Chris Bryant of
course it is majority uh conservative
for three of those who are on the
committee
I want to ask you about Sue gray if I
may and the fact that she was apparently
advising the committee while she was
speaking to the opposition about a new
post working for securma
um perception is not good there is a
I think that Sue gray made I think
difficult to say an error let's to take
it two ways is it wrong for a former
civil servant to go and work for a
political party no it is not and do I
think that Sue gray is as a consequence
of doing a shift in some way tainted in
her approach to being a civil servant in
the years before and I have to say
having known her for many years uh when
she's been a civil servant over the last
10 years or more I'm absolutely
satisfied about her impartiality and
Independence on every subject so from
that point of view the shift
um that she has decided to make to
becoming here starman's chief of staff
is one which in my view is perfectly
acceptable the timing one has to say did
come across as rather unfortunate in all
the circumstances but that's that's a
matter of presentation I don't happen to
think that Sue gray is in any way biased
all that her bias uh it was present at
all when she was a civil servant in
Downing Street in Whiteville I
understand that
um Mr grieve but perception is reality
and she was she put together a report
which eventually brought down the then
prime minister she was advising a
committee which is looking into the
actions of the then prime minister
um and he's at the same time talking to
the opposition
but she did her time she did her report
I'm not aware that at that stage she was
talking to Kia stammer about becoming
his chief of staff at pool there's any
evidence of that whatsoever but she was
when she was talking to the committee
well she may have been when she was
talking to the committee but she wasn't
when she did her report and ultimately
it's her report which certainly uh
helped bring the Prime Minister down but
you only have to look at the content of
the report to see it would be very
difficult for the report to say anything
else because it was backed up by a huge
amount of evidence
quick thought before I let you go on the
situation as far as the Home Secretary
is concerned and
see happening she says that she'll be
sending people to Rwanda by these summer
I shall work with interest to see how
many people actually get sent to Rwanda
by the Home Secretary I think it's a
policy which is fraught with difficulty
and uh it will be interesting to see
whether this policy actually works or
not
it's always great to see you thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you
foreign
coming up we are going to be talking
about Boris Johnson again he is making
headlines yet again uh today we're
asking you what should happen if he's
been found to recklessly mislead
Parliament Paulo um saying when I was a
UK civil servant we were told in no
uncertain terms that misleading
Parliament was a crime punishable
accordingly therefore you would expect
ministers to be under a stricter
requirement than civil servants at the
very least the same that's what Paulo
says what do you think do let us know
what should happen to Boris Johnson if
he's found to have recklessly misled
Parliament we're going to be hearing his
defense later on today and then box
office two o'clock Wednesday afternoon
you'll be giving his evidence live to
the committee watch it here on Skies
unisex
foreign